cuáles de las siguientes expresiones
representan la distancia entre c y d
veamos aquí está d
y aquí estás
y sabemos que la distancia entre dos
números es el valor absoluto de uno de
los números de menos el valor del otro
número que en este caso es c y también
puede ser al revés puedo tener
- de pero voy a obtener el valor
absoluto del resultado y ambos estos dos
son iguales porque estamos hablando del
valor absoluto de estos resultados vamos
a ver si yo sustituyó d
- e
el valor absoluto voy a tener que de
tres cuartos tres cuartos menos si se es
menos un cuarto así que se es menos sen
y se vale menos un cuarto restar menos
un cuarto es equivalente a sumar un
cuarto me queda tres cuartos más un
cuarto ahora esto es en este caso de de
menos pero igual lo puedo hacer para el
caso de ser menos d
lo cambió aqui en otro color para que se
note
en el caso de que tengo ce menos de el
valor absoluto de esto tengo que ser es
menos un cuarto menos un cuarto menos de
y de tres cuartos menos tres cuartos
cierro paréntesis siero el valor
absoluto y que me queda el valor
absoluto de menos un cuarto menos tres
cuartos
en ambos casos voy a tener aquí menos un
cuarto menos tres cuartos van a ser
menos cuatro cuartos el valor absoluto y
aquí voy a tener tres cuartos más un
cuarto en el valor absoluto de cuatro
cuartos
y estos dos son iguales porque cuando
estamos viendo el valor absoluto es la
distancia la distancia de cero al punto
d en este caso esta distancia y de cero
al punto cero esta distancia de acá
entonces no importa si yo estoy restando
uno de otro o al revés cuando toma el
valor absoluto va a ser la distancia que
hay entre estos dos números y la
distancia entre estos dos números es
cuatro cuartos y aquí también aquí son
cuatro cuartos que es lo mismo que uno
entera pero lo dejamos con los cuatro
cuartos para que se note y aquí el valor
absoluto quitamos este signo el valor
absoluto el valor absoluto de menos
cuatro cuartos es también 44 estos son
iguales y esta es la distancia pero
bueno lo que nos preguntan es las
opciones cuáles de estas opciones son
correctas
mi primera opción es menos un cuarto más
tres cuartos vamos a ver esto que ya
desarrollamos donde tenemos menos un
cuarto y aquí está menos un cuarto menos
tres cuartos y aquí me dicen es menos un
cuarto más tres cuartos aquí no tengo
esto en ninguna opción tengo esto así
que esta no me sirve la siguiente - un
cuarto
- tres cuartos a esta si la tengo acá
justamente es esta
está aquí está así que está así es una
opción
no elijo esta porque bueno si es una de
estas anteriores
esta es la correcta vamos a ver otro
ejercicio
elige la recta numérica que concuerda
con la expresión valor absoluto de 81
veamos si recordamos la fórmula del
valor absoluto es que tenemos una letra
que representa un número y le restamos
otro número y del resultado tomamos el
valor absoluto suponiendo que a es 8
porque éste es a
tendría que hacer la fórmula de a b s
sería b sería en este caso 8 - b pero b
vale menos 1
entonces en este caso sería 8 - menos 1
que sería 81 el valor absoluto de esto
que no coincide con esto así que ésta no
es veamos la siguiente
ahora en este caso va a seguir siendo
este 8 y ve va a ser éste uno este va a
ser b
ponemos a 8 - ve ve vale 18
1 aquí si corresponde esta fórmula con
esta expresión así que esta es mi opción
correcta aquí si encontré una veamos
otro problema más una tortuga reta al
guerrero griego aquiles a una carrera
afuera de las puertas de troya vamos a
imaginarnos que estas son las puertas de
troya no sé cómo eran pero me las
imagino así
y aquí va a estar la tortuga
muy atrevida por haber retado al
guerrero aquiles y aquí voy a dibujar
y aquí es con su obra
porque es viejo la tortuga y aquí les
empiezan a las puertas de troya y corren
en línea recta alejándose de la ciudad
nos imaginamos que quiere atrás está la
ciudad de troya y ambos comienzan
alejándose en línea recta
corriendo a toda velocidad alejándose de
la ciudad nos dicen a la mitad de la
carrera aquí les está a efe pies de las
puertas vamos a poner aquí entonces que
aquí les está a efe pies ésta es 'una
efe la distancia que ya recorrió aquiles
y la tortuga está solo je pies de las
puertas pues yo no sé cuál es la
distancia me están diciendo nada más fg
vamos a suponer que después la tortuga
quizás no está tan adelantada como
aquiles o lo mejor adelantó más quién
sabe pero vamos a imaginar que la
distancia de la tortuga lo que ha
recorrido la tortuga es ésta
cuál de las siguientes expresiones
siempre representa la distancia entre la
tortuga y aquiles durante la carrera
recordemos nuevamente la fórmula de la
distancia entre números es el valor
absoluto de uno de los números menos el
otro número aquí vamos a poner que la
distancia entre la tortuga y la tortuga
es g
menos la distancia que tiene aquiles
durante la carrera que es
efe el valor absoluto de esto esta es
nuestra fórmula o también puede ser al
revés siempre que estemos tomando el
valor absoluto no importa cuál sea el
orden de estos dos números nos va a
servir el valor absoluto de f
- g la distancia de aquiles menos la de
la tortuga y el valor absoluto de esta
cantidad cualquiera de estas dos nos
representa la distancia que hay entre la
tortuga y aquiles veamos las opciones
tenemos el valor absoluto df más que uno
aquí tenemos o menos f más g efe - g
ésta no nos sirve esta no el valor
absoluto de efe - g es así coincide aquí
tengo mi f que es la distancia de
aquiles menos g que es la distancia de
la tortuga
el valor absoluto de su diferencia esta
es la opción correcta y yo espero que
con esto les haya quedado más claro cómo
aplicar la fórmula de la distancia entre
dos números en problemas o enunciados
prácticos